James keratini est ancien professeur de
techno il est directeur de l'association
sciences réunion pour la diffusion de la
culture scientifique mais il est avant
tout un plongeur passionné de
photographie sous-marine auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages sur la faune
subaquatique ces images ont souvent été
primées lors de festivals de photos
sous-marines il collabore aussi avec le
Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle la Faculté
des Sciences l'Aquarium de La Réunion ou
encore le parc marin il partage
aujourd'hui avec nous sa passion lors
d'une plongée sur la passe de l'Ermitage
je suis arrivé à l'île de la Réunion il
y a à peu près 25 ans j'étais déjà très
très orienté photographies mais
notamment terrestre et en arrivant l'île
de la Réunion moi je me suis tout de
suite équipé j'étais plongeur et j'ai
pris le virus de la photo sous-marine
donc il y a 25 ans
on est passé par des stades de gros gros
travail de prise de vue et de vraiment
un travail sur la lumière sur sur la
composition sur sur l'analyse de l'image
et sur l'analyse vraiment des réglages à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple
actuellement je veux dire un photographe
maintenant qui a un juste un bon regard
grâce à une nouvelle vidéo nouvelle
technologie peut progresser beaucoup
plus vite qu'à l'époque
c'est vrai que c'est une activité où il
faut il faut il faut pas les trop vite
sur cette partie là de se dire je plonge
je fais de la photo tout de suite il
faut quand même passer par un stade de
formation on les clope sont là pour ça
donc arriver à bien maîtriser la plongée
avant tout avant de commencer à
envisager de faire de l'image
les images qu'on a pu faire ce matin
alors on est parti dans des conditions
un peu difficiles vous avez pu constater
et on se rend compte que on a eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'on est parti
sur un site ou du monde du coup il y
avait personne on s'est retrouvé qu'à
deux à deux plongeurs sous l'eau sur un
site qui est quand même très très prisé
donc la passe de l'Ermitage et du coup
on sent tout de suite quand il y a pas
trop de monde parce que les animaux sont
plus calmes ils sont on va dire presque
plus réceptif
le monde du silence c'est pas pour rien
donc ça fait du bien de temps en temps
de se retrouver justement un peu un peu
tranquille et puis faire de l'image bon
ben c'est une façon aussi de communier
avec la nature de
l'animalier c'est toujours quelque chose
c'est un don de la nature on va dire
parce qu'on peut très bien faire une
plongée pas avoir grand chose ce matin
c'était que du bonheur magnifique